alors que ça devait être une séquence
bienveillante et positive voilà que la
vidéo de l'équipe de france rendant
hommage à samuel patty a réalisé un bad
buzz
une vidéo dont le contenu et les propos
des joueurs présents ne prêtent pourtant
pas à la polémique
aller à l'école c'est une chance une
chance que vous offre la république
française à travers ce professeur sauf
que c'est précisément le problème ce ne
sont pas les joueurs présents qui
dérange des internautes mais ceux qui
sont absents pour plusieurs personnes
sur les réseaux l'absence de diversité
dans la vidéo pose problème
les joueurs stars comme kilian est
mbappé paul pogba ou encore presnell
kimbembe dont l'absence a dérangé
certains internautes
alors comprenez vous la polémique sur
l'absence de diversité dans la vidéo
hommage à samuel pâtit alors oui je suis
le premier à faire nous avons enquêté
ouais je suis le premier à avoir
toujours des polémiques syrie mais là
franchement pour moi y'en a pas l'idée
vient de jean michel blanquer
le ministre de l'éducation nationale il
reçoit tout le monde le jeudi 22 octobre
soit noël le graet le président de la
fédération française il lui dit on
devrait lancer une initiative
il confirme l'initiative le mardi
d'après et la fédé a eu deux jours alors
que les joueurs étaient en coupe
d'europe comme bape et les autres pour
faire ça ils ont remis la vidéo le
vendredi ils ont eu ce qu'ils pouvaient
ngolo quand et voulait le faire il a dit
mais j'ai pas le temps
les joueurs étaient en club ils sont
durs à joindre ils doivent demander des
autorisations nous dit qu'il ya pas de
polémique franchement d'abord lui on
peut le croire mais moi ce qui me fâche
dans cette histoire c'est que c'est
justement ces personnes qui ont un
problème avec ce fait-là qui qui sont
racistes pour moi je disais de le dire
mais quand tu vois une différence entre
les blancs les noirs les machins c'est
qu'il ya un problème si ça saute aux
yeux ce responsable
non mais c'est parce qu'ils sont
musulmans noirs
[Musique]
quand on fait rien on est on est on est
passé quand on fait quelque chose moi je
trouve que c'est une très bonne ministre
et si leur tape la fédération française
de football et voilà tous les joueurs
n'ont pas pu participer je suis sûr
qu'ils ont aujourd'hui bape et
camaradière sera fermé oui éclats puis
on dit à berlin